is time to tee off at the tpc some
big-name golfers they are back on the
green for the shriners open which we've
learned will now be staying in las vegas
for the foreseeable future that's right
victoria saha live this morning at tpc
summerlin working on her iron game now i
think victoria instead of the putting
him working on the irons now victoria
and good morning to you
good morning to you both yep we're here
at the putting green where as you can
see behind me some golfers are already
practicing i've been practicing as well
i'm going to have a confession this is
my first time holding a golf club so i'm
going to have patrick lindsay hold my
microphone while i give this a shot
it was a quick lesson hopefully she's
a good study a quick study
not too bad okay one more
oh that one has a chance oh
just missed it
all right so
in 2019 they had over over 70 000 fans
with 144 players from all around the
world they're kind of expecting the same
turnout this year right yeah that's
right you know we're really excited for
what this week is going to be we feel
like our ticket sales are currently on
pace for what they were 19. let me tell
you we're just so like refreshed to be
able to welcome fans back and see
smiling faces come around and watch this
product and see the golf and experience
the charity and can you name some of the
top golf players
absolutely brooks kepka scottie
scheffler victor hovland ricky fowler
adam scott louis hazen and hideki
matsuyama who just won the masters
earlier this year so it's going to be a
great field this year for all the fans
coming out to watch and why is this
event so important to you guys well it's
all about the charity for us in shriners
children's and helping them spread a
mission of providing the most amazing
care anywhere regardless of the family's
ability to pay
we're talking about the specialties of
orthopedic conditions prosthetics burn
care cleft lip cleft palate spinal cord
injuries those are the services that
shriners provides and that's what you'll
see here on site and make sure that
we're providing those services to kids
around the world thanks so much
obviously such an important event
tickets are thirty dollars john and
heather i'm gonna send it back to you
guys